how are you doing today sir
i'm good steve uh i just want to start
with then i think i've told you this in
the past i'm a huge fan of your work
it is a uh it's a real thrill to talk to
you today
well thank you um so i have to start
with uh
uh i want to go back to earlier in your
career and i'm very curious
how long did it take for you to forgive
lawrence kasdan from cutting you out
on the big chill well i have a different
view of that he
he basically really you know helped
launch my career
um and he had nothing to uh i
i was the moment he the part was mine
i actually thought my career was
happening
that was even before we shot it then we
shot it the movie came out it was a
giant hit and i wasn't in it
what you have to understand is i i yeah
of course i would have liked to be in of
course all the friends who knew i was
going to be in it i had to explain that
i wasn't in it
but honestly everything that needed to
happen to me
his endorsement of me him putting me in
it
my career was in motion and if i thought
that was my one and only chance
to be in a movie i might have been
disappointed if i was a
person just plucked off the street and
said hey would you stand in for this
role for a second and then it got cut
out
you know maybe maybe i'm incredibly
disappointed because that was my
i felt that everything that needed to
happen happened uh
that experience informed me a lot about
how i
conducted myself well also you got to
spend time on set and learn
from a great filmmaker uh how how it all
works
that's exactly what i mean it all it all
happened for me
there so many things i was able to take
away from that experience
uh is it safe to assume that this movie
is taking place
in like an alt universe where a baby
from the sky didn't land in your and
diane's
yard i'm talking about superman
yeah see well i i it's not that i
understand your question
you broke up halfway through but uh yeah
i
i
get what you're saying mom paul can't um
well you know it's safe to say that i
didn't know where this story was gonna
go when i read it
i knew diane was gonna be a part of it
so that was a plus
but it took me on a real authentic
journey and it took me
it's right away as a kind of a
foreboding
happened and and it never let up
uh it's a man understanding that his
wife is on a mission
and she won't be stopped and it's a
measure of love it's a measure of
stubbornness it's a measure of ah but
we've all been there
and i thought that it was just magically
worked a movie
you know we saw a real relationship a
real love story set against almost a
horror film if you will
yeah one of the things that i really
responded to is your character
um doesn't speak a lot and it's only
when he feels like he has to say
something um can you sort of talk about
was that always in the script
did you sort of add to that in terms of
like the minimal dialogue
no it was a beautiful script i i just uh
elected to take my my time with that
because
i mean i could see the words and i
understood that they were measured
and i think uh with our the women in our
life we actually have to
choose our words carefully especially
when someone
is emotionally charged as uh the diane
character was
um it was an interesting
platform in which to get to this this
ending that was
we don't really see coming but we could
guess that and george could guess at it
completely um the other thing i really
responded to is that
you know there's a lot of actors that
might not be willing to play someone
who gets their ass kicked um i and one
of the things about
your character is he's not superhuman
he's a normal person
um and uh can you sort of talk about
that that you you know you
you're playing someone with limitations
in this film yeah he was limited
as a result of some of the details of
the film i don't want to really
give away but you know we can learn a
lot
in defeat and i remember watching a
giant
and seeing um rock hudson in that
particular movie who was a bigot a
racist if you will as an epic movie
george stevens about three hours long
and i remember at the end life had dealt
him a lot of realities a lot of blows i
don't know if you know the movie i
didn't get or
started at all but he ends up in a in a
diner
with his mexican grandchild and he
fights
because he sees the the child
discriminate against and the mother
humiliated that it was discriminated
against and he fights with a man a
korean vet
and you have this typical hollywood
beautiful star
rock hudson fighting this epic fist
fight and he loses
he gets beat up that's not how movies
normally go
and in the end he's sitting against the
wall defeated
the guy actually puts a sign over his
head but he fought for his grandchild
and at the end
elizabeth taylor goes over to him and
sees this man
who traditionally won historically won
and in defeat she looked at the reason
he fought and she says you never stood
taller
and we can learn something from the
movies
about how we conduct ourselves our
gestures
what we commit to about you know trying
to
protect the people we love from their
own worst instincts
and he does lose i get that but it
didn't
bother me i understood
that you don't always win on that note i
need to go
i just want to say congrats on the movie
and as always a pleasure to talk to you
thank you